- We are right on the hinge.
We're right on the edge
of a national divorce.
Now, I have a
contrarian view on this,
which is I actually think
the sooner we built the,
build the parallel economy,
and we have these other mediums,
I actually think it deescalates
the chance for a
national divorce.
I think it's the exact opposite-
- [Dave] Yeah, I like that.
I got it.
- Actually,
it's kinda like, "All right,
you do you; we do us."
Like, maybe we can have like
a five-year cooling off period
before we actually sign
the divorce papers, right?
And I don't think,
I think the more that we
live under their tyranny,
you're gonna see real
radicalism rise up,
that I hate and you hate, right?
Where people are starting
to talk about things that-
I don't want the
country to break up.
I think it's an awful thing.
It's my home, it's your home.
I don't wanna have to show
a passport when I go to LAX.
It's like I want that to
be my fellow countryman.
(smooth funky music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and
joining me today is the host
of the Charlie Kirk Show,
the founder of
Turning Point USA,
and the author of
The MAGA Doctrine:
The Only Ideas That
Will Win the Future,
Charlie Kirk, old friend.
Welcome back to
the Rubin Report.
- Dave, you're a good friend.
Honor to be here.
Thank you for having me.
- We've done this
a couple times,
and I thought, "How can
I approach this interview
in a way that's a
little different
than what we've done before?"
so I thought we'd start off.
Give me your top 10
reasons you love Joe Biden.
- Top 10 reasons
I love Joe Biden.
That's, I will say
he's actually made me
prioritize things
in life that matter.
Not to say politics
don't matter,
but it's been such
a dumpster fire,
you have to kinda look
outside of all the madness,
and you're like, "Okay, what
really matters in life?" right?
Like, what, exactly, gives
you purpose and meaning?
'Cause obviously, the
things that we used to,
I used to look at the presidency
as something I revere,
and I guess I still do,
and I love my country,
but he's been so awful.
It's like, "Okay,
there's a couple things
I can control in my life,
like family and relationships,
friendships, career, and I'm
gonna focus on those things,"
and it's kinda the-
One of the few things I
wanna thank Joe Biden for
is he has reinforced,
at least for me,
things that I control and
things I cannot control.
Unfortunately, I can't
control the southern border.
I can talk about it.
It's wide open and
it's a total disaster,
but besides that,
I'm not sure what else I
would put on that list, Dave?
- I thought maybe you
could come up with three.
I thought maybe there
were gonna be three,
but I'll accept that,
but for a guy like you-
- Well, I-
- Yeah, go ahead.
- Well, I mean, I guess
if you wanna kinda do
the whole like
glass-half-full thing
and the perpetual
optimist thing,
and the best thing
about being surrounded
is you can shoot in
any direction thing,
which is basically, look,
I do think that there's been
unintended consequences of what
this regime has been
trying to implement
which is the rise of
the citizen and try-
- I knew you were
gonna get there,
that was one of the
three I had in there.
- Right, and like the the
homeschooling revolution
and people really caring
about their country again,
and there is a window,
there's an opportunity,
there's a chance,
there's a sliver,
I don't think it's
by any chance certain
that this backfires on them
so dramatically that it
could be a political
realignment.
The likes of which our
generation has we haven't seen
in 30 or 40 years.
- Do you believe in the
machine enough to believe
that something like
that could happen?
Because that's the direction
I thought you were gonna go
because it's like
everything is so bad,
everything is so upside
down, even for guys like us
who expected this
thing to be bad,
it's worse than most of
us could have imagined,
but do you think the machine
will allow like just in the
last couple days watching
the narrative on COVID shift,
like do you think it'll allow
what should happen to happen?
That the voice of the people
will actually be heard?
- Well, thankfully-
- Between the media
and the whole thing.
That's what I'm talking.
- Yeah, well, no for
sure, of course, yeah.
Thankfully critical parts of
the machine are falling apart
which gives me hope.
I mean CNN is basically
a Democrat super PAC
that no one watches,
Facebook is cratering which
is really really interesting
to see Rumble, which you
and I really care about
is ascending, so there are
certain trends right now
that kinda go into maybe
the machine isn't as strong
as it once was.
Americans' trust in
government is an all time low,
Americans' trust in corporations
are at all time low.
You're starting to see
people care more about local
than national trends which
is really really important,
I think the machine is
way weaker than it was
even a year ago, and let
alone five years ago,
I think that there is kinda
like a natural law component
to this, where if
you try to build
a multi-trillion
dollar oligarchy or
oligopoly, I should say
the laws of gravity are probably
gonna push back against you
at some point.
There will be leaks
and dissension, civil
war, fracturing,
and you're seeing a lot of that
not just within
the Democrat party,
but within a lot of the super
structures that you and I
believe the actual
power is vested in.
So look, I could have a
cynical take where I'm like,
"You know what?
These people always have power.
The infrastructure
is impenetrable,"
but I'm not so sure of that.
I think that there is a
revival to challenge all these
institutions, and Dave, you've
played a really important
part in this which is those
of us that love freedom,
and love the Constitution
as the greatest
political document ever,
we're building our
own infrastructure,
we're building our own machine,
and that's been a
really exciting trend.
I think the regime is
really surprised by it.
I think they're
shocked quite honestly,
that we've been able to kinda
stand up a YouTube competitor,
a payment processing competitor,
a Patreon competitor
like locals so quickly.
You're starting to see a
higher education competitor
of University of Austin,
and all of a sudden this kind
of, this monopoly they had
on these certain
goods and services,
and credentialing institutions
is being challenged
in a very serious way,
but they're still way more
powerful than us,
there's no doubt.
But I'm optimistic that there
might be some legitimate fault
lines that are gonna
materialize in their demise.
- That would be a slightly
better great reset
than the great reset that
they've been telling us about.
But I'm curious for you,
look I know you, I know you
off camera too, at this point,
but I don't know that I've ever
fully asked you this before.
Like you know, you were so
obviously a close associate
and through Turning Point
in the Trump's campaign
and you wrote the book the Maga
Doctrine and the whole thing
to go from that and I
would go to Turning Point
the night that I met
Trump at Mar a Lago,
we were at dinner that very
night there, and it was after
an event you put together
and all that stuff,
and I say that because you
were so associated with that,
now he's not in power, and I
just wonder for you personally,
like what did the
last year show?
I'm not talking about the
political part of my guy's
not in power anymore,
but just like the other,
you were part of something
that was fun and cool,
at least from our perspective,
and now you ain't in it.
Or you know, the thing
exists, but like it's not
in power anymore so like,
what does that just
personally for you like?
- Well, first it was
really demoralizing,
not from like an access
standpoint or like the fact
you could call the
president, like whatever,
it was just kinda demoralizing
for the country, right?
I mean especially the month of
January, we're like, "Okay."
At New Year's I remember
thinking, "All right, okay,
Biden's gonna be president.
The very least we can win these
Senate races in Georgia.
We can have a check in
balance, separation of powers."
And then January 5th
happened, they're like,
"Okay, we lost that," and
then January 6th happened,
which was a catastrophe
right, for a variety
of different reasons, and
so it was a demoralizing
couple weeks in 2021, and our
team at Turning Point USA,
which has always been
educationally focused
and our team at the
Charlie Kirk show
which has obviously
been very aligned
with the Trump doctrine
and his worldview,
what do we stand for?
And we really went to work.
I traveled 330 days
in the year of 2021,
and went to campuses and
churches, and we didn't talk
a lot about Trump honestly,
and we didn't talk
about Biden either.
More than anything else, we
talked about what it meant
to be an American and
what we stood for,
and why we stood for it.
And it was definitely this
moment where I also had to kind
of reintroduce myself to a
lot of people that just kinda
knew me as, "Oh you're the guy
that defends Trump, right?"
and it was, I think
very well received
in a lot of different ways.
And I also think it forced
our team and our show
to go a level deeper.
I spent more time in 2021
of reading deep books
and spending time in
very complex philosophy
and really challenging my
ideas and why I believe it
and where does it come from?
Because it wasn't
just kind of like,
"Okay the left is
out of their mind.
We have to defend the
president we have,
'cause he's doing
a really good job."
And you could kind of get
really used to that, right?
But then all of a sudden when
he is displaced from power,
there's a lot of
people that are saying,
"Okay, do we want to go
back to like the Liz Cheney
kind of way of doing things?
Or why do we want borders
to be controlled?"
And so you have to
kinda come from that
with an approach that is
philosophically based,
and rooted in a natural
rights doctrine and also in
timeless ideas while also
respecting the fruits of the
enlightenment, all these
really important things.
And so I think that we're
better because of it, honestly.
I think our show's
more interesting,
I think our organization
is stronger,
I think we're
reaching more people,
and I'm not to say not
to say that I'm thankful,
I mean the country's
in horrible shape,
but I think we were
able to use what was
an adversarial situation,
or a set of circumstances
to our advantage.
- Do you think that they
think that they're doing good?
I mean, this is a little
bit of the road to hell
kinda situation.
Like do you think, I mean I
don't know if Biden's in charge
at this point, which if
you wanna comment on that,
feel free, but like when
they all put their heads
on the pillow when Saki
lays down at night,
Biden, the rest of them,
the surgeon general,
all of these people that are
associated with this thing,
Fauci, all of them.
Do you really think they're
looking at the information
looking at what's going on here?
Supply chain, inflation,
Afghanistan, et cetera
and going, "Boy we really
are doing a great job?"
- Man, you ask good questions.
I gotta tell you I ask
questions too every day,
and this it's a great question,
'cause I get this all
the time and people say,
"What is the motive?" Right?
"How do they how do
they judge success?
Like what does the whiteboard
look like in the outer room
of the oval?" Right?
Like, are we going towards
the mission accomplished,
or are we getting
further away from it?
And this is a hard
thing for some people
on the center right, or people
that love the Constitution
to admit.
It's not hard for me to admit
because I kind of understand
the left really well.
I think they're right on
schedule for what they want.
And I really do believe that
they want to be a willing
participant in the world
economic forum Great Reset.
You mentioned it a little
bit sarcastically earlier,
but you and I both know this
is a very real agenda which is
a borderless society,
- It's legit,
I just did an hour
with Glen Beck on it.
- Yeah, and it's I think
that in order to get there,
you have to first make America
no longer a superpower.
And that doesn't mean you
have to kill everybody right?
I mean, I think there's
some extremes people
can take towards
describing this,
but you definitely have
to destroy our currency,
You have to deteriorate
our sovereignty.
You have to erode
the national will.
And then also you have to
create mass uncertainty
as to what it means
to be an American.
And the person that's probably
done the best job of this
is Nicole Hannah Jones
from the 1619 project.
It's something we talk
about every single day
at Turning Point USA,
which if you can't tell an
agreed upon American story,
then you just don't
have a country.
I mean it's such polar
opposites where you and I
would look at the
American founding as
a heroic breakthrough
of the human story, where
Nicole Hannah Jones look
looks at it as a regressive
moment in the human story.
There really isn't
much in common
from that point forward, right?
When you can't agree on
the Federalist papers,
the Declaration,
the Constitution,
the Bill of Rights,
and so I believe that the
people in charge from Ron Klain
to Biden, they might have their
own little kind of wrinkles
of where they think
the country should go,
but it's definitely in a place
where they wanna de-emphasize
America's role in the world.
They want to weaken America,
and they think the world
will be better because of it.
This is the most
important thing though.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is that in the beginning
of Aristotle's ethics,
there's this incredible line
that is hotly debated
which is, "All human action
points towards some good."
Now, you take out the mentally
and politically insane
from that, but really
what he's getting at
is that more evil has been
done under people believing
that they're doing good
than anything else.
You take Joseph Stalin.
He actually thought he was
bettering humanity or bettering
himself or whatever.
Very few people are actually,
"Yes, I'm doing what
is wrong, and I'm gonna
keep on doing it."
It's a very rare thing.
And I think that these
people in charge,
and no I don't think
Biden's in charge,
I think he's a puppet, be
for all these other masters.
I actually don't think
very much about Biden,
I actually really haven't
engaged much in kinda the mental
decline kind of meme
verse if you will.
I think it's a little overdone.
We all kinda know
he's not there.
I'm more interested in
the people behind him,
and the reason they're
doing all this,
but yes, I think that from
the Treasury Secretary
Janet Yellen to Mayorkas,
to the Educational Secretary
to all of them, I
think that they believe
that they are all doing what
a good comrade should do
to try and usher in a
globalist type project
and the American superpower
status of a strong economy,
being energy independent,
a sound currency,
and a national story
that we all agree on.
Those are things that
are right at the heart
of their agenda.
- Do you think
that conservatives,
whatever this new wide tent
thing is at this point,
this anti-woke coalition and
we'll see how how tightly
it can hold.
Do you think we just
need a better story?
Do you think the story of just
telling the American history
say the way we've seen it,
or the way that you and I
have talked about
it for a long time,
that maybe that isn't enough.
Just going back to say
Reagan talking points
as good and decent as they are,
like do we need a new story,
a new narrative to craft
to capture young people?
I mean obviously that's what
you guys are trying to do
at Turning Point, but
is just saying freedom,
and individual rights
and capitalism,
is it not enough that there
has to be something else
behind that too?
- It's not enough, but it
will be enough this year,
which worries me.
It will be enough to take
back power for Republicans
and defeat the woke, just
to run against the woke.
They're so unpopular.
They're so awful at governing.
And that's the thing Dave,
is that not only do they have
bad ideas, they're
actually bad at executing
their bad ideas.
I mean, it's like
the worst possible-
- Thank God, sort of?
- kinda combin-
Well, no that's the thing where
I had, I gotten this debate
the other day and someone
says, "Charlie, we need more
technology in government so
they can be more efficient."
I'm like, "I'm actually really
glad that they're slow."
- Yeah.
- I'm really glad that
they take Arbor Day off.
Because if they didn't,
then they'd be like Google
which we know how
harmful they can be,
which we'll get into the
whole corporate side of this.
But I'm worried because I'm
afraid that there's gonna be
kind of a false stimulus
effect to the conservative
movement, that like all we
have to do is run against
the woke, we take back
every chamber of power,
like the Glen
Youngkin thing, right?
Where I'm afraid that we're
gonna need a lot more.
And I'll give you an example
of what a lot more looks like,
which I think conservatives
need to think very deeply
about a national
recovery program.
I think that this country
has been so severely damaged
by unelected bureaucrats,
especially young people,
most suicidal, drug
addicted, alcohol addicted,
most anxious, depressed,
medicated generation in history,
that I think there needs to be
an intergenerational apology
to try to get this
generation back on track.
And I'm not saying massive
government programs or some sort
of climate core like AOC wants,
but I think we should
try to make it easier
to try to have
conservatizing events.
And the three conservatizing
events, if you will
just accept the term,
is to own property,
to get married, and have kids,
and hopefully a nice fourth one
is have a job that means
something to you right?
That isn't like a minimum
wage job or some sort of
woke social media
manager for Goldman Sachs
or whatever right?
Those four things are harder
than ever for this generation
to grab onto.
And I think that we need
to have pro market based
conversations outside of
just kind of the immediate
muscle memory of the
dogma of the kinda ghosts
of Reagan past, and say,
"How do we make it easier
for a 28 year old that's a
$100,000 in student loan debt,
that was locked down for
a couple years, right?
Is really demoralized?
Might be on an unnecessary
regimen of antidepressants,
how do we make it easier
for them to break through
and buy quote unquote "equity"
in the American project,
right?"
Because that actually
is a really good thing
for the country.
People don't burn down Wendys
if they have a mortgage.
When you're renting all
the time, you become
you become a perfect population
that could be captured
by these kind of woke
socialist revolutionaries.
And so no, I don't think
it's just enough to kind of
have the slogans.
I think we need to think
creatively about these things
and I think we also need
to know why we believe in
what we believe it.
The Constitution needs
to be our north star.
It is the greatest
political document ever.
Nothing we should do should
violate the four basic tenants
of the Constitution:
separation of powers,
consent to the governed,
independent judiciary,
and balance of power, basically.
Those are, that's the core
basis of the US Constitution,
but with that being
said though, Dave,
I think that we have portions
of the American population
that have been so set
back by the lockdowns
and government interference
that if we don't come up
with something more
robust or exciting,
we're gonna be looking at a
potential political population
that will entertain
seriously radical ideas.
- Right, I mean how
much worse it could be
if we don't do something to
heal some of these wounds.
You accidentally said
ghosts of Rogan past.
- I know.
- We'll get to that.
We'll get to that.
- It was a total slip.
You're right.
- That will be a
hell of a segue.
We're gonna slide into
when we talk about big tech
in just a little bit.
But you said something
interesting there about
the intergenerational
version of this.
And I've been thinking
about this a lot,
that so many of the people
that are in power right now,
or at least appear
to be in power,
say Joe Biden, say Nancy Pelosi,
any of these people,
really any of them,
Diane Feinstein, who everyone
knows is almost incapacitated
at this point.
Just the amount of they're
not, I guess they're
upper end boomers, but
they're also the last
of the great generation,
something like that,
but these people that are
in their say mid seventies
and up that are still
clinging to power,
Nancy Pelosi with that
ridiculous reelection video
from two weeks ago, and
it's like lady you're 81.
Go be a grandma, like, enough.
Do you think there's something?
What do you think that
is psychologically maybe
about that generation
that they can't let go.
Because that does seem
to be a big problem here,
and I've seen in just
in the last couple weeks
that suddenly, Gen X, I'm 45
right in the middle of Gen X,
like my generation, you're you
are a little younger than me,
so you're not you're Gen
Y is that fair to say?
- I'm a millennial, yeah.
- You're a millennial
no offense,
but that 35
- I'm 28.
- Right, but the 35,
36, to say 54 year olds,
we just haven't
had our chance yet.
Because for some reason,
those people kept hanging on
at every level.
Do you think there's something
psychologically going on
there that didn't
allow them to let go?
- Yeah, you're gonna get me
in a lot of trouble, Dave
'cause we talk about this a lot.
And the angriest e-mails
I get are on this topic,
so buckle up, I suppose.
- [Dave] Right?
- You said something super
interesting which Nancy Pelosi,
go be a grandma,
and she kinda still sees herself
as this like 33 year old,
kind of like AIDs Crusader
in west San Francisco.
That is gonna
take over
- The eyebrows
- the Democratic party-
- keep getting higher.
- Yeah but do you
know what I mean?
Which is like okay, like
you've had your chance,
go look beyond yourself.
That's what a grandma's
all about right?
- [Dave] Yeah, yeah.
- Like go look about, go look
towards the next generation
and are you actually
preserving things
that are beautiful,
true, and good?
For her it's kind of like
no I still have to have
that one more election cycle,
you don't understand,
because that's when
the real revolution
is gonna happen.
And so look, I mean it's the
tyranny of the septuagenarians
and the octogenarians, and
there's a lot of great people
in the seventies and eighties
category in our country,
it just so happens none of them
are in leadership right now.
(Dave laughs)
- [Dave] Right, right.
- So it just so happens
that the cream that
whatever's risen to
the top isn't the best.
And so you kinda have a through
line of Biden and Schumer
and Pelosi that have been in
this shtick for 30 or 40 years,
literally, and they don't
really care about the damage
they're leaving to
the next generation.
It's kinda like they wanna
have their two to four years
to rule over the ashes,
and they're gonna die.
And I hate to be
so morbid about it,
but they're on the back
nine of the back nine
they're on like hole 17, right?
And so you gotta start to
all of a sudden look like
who's the next group of people
that are gonna be playing?
Now you've had Eric Weinstein
on your program before,
he talks about the ego, the
embedded growth obligation.
I think that's a really smart
perspective about how this is
a generation that has
literally experienced nothing
but prosperity economically
their entire life
and has gotten used to it and
acts as if that is something
that is just kinda baked
in the human existence.
Things get better,
don't get in my way.
But I think that the entire
way that we reacted to COVID
kind of exposes all of this.
I think it does so in
bright and dramatic colors,
which is, it really is kind of
the first modern civilization
that has willingly sacrificed
the young to placate the old,
and there is no other
way to describe it.
I mean some people will
reject the premise,
but we went from shutting down
schools 'cause it might hurt
kids to shutting down schools,
because they might transmit
a virus to grandma.
That's a totally different
moral argument by the way,
totally different.
For the first moral
argument is like,
"Okay it might kill young
people," I get that.
The next is, "Oh now
they might get infected
and they might kill grandma."
I'm not into that obviously,
I wanna protect seniors,
but that's a totally different
argument which is like
okay we must inhibit
your development,
We must suppress your life
experience and your activities
because you might then hurt
the generation that does not
have as many years left to live.
And so yes, I think an
intergenerational apology
is necessary, totally.
And I will say that kinda
that 35 to 54 year old bracket
is the, I think, it is
going to be in my opinion,
the great swing to the
right that no one expected.
I think there's more
red pilling happening
between ages 35 to 54.
And there's a lot of boomers
that are really conservative
and God bless them for that,
and they continue to be,
but there is kinda this
question of like the 42 year old
mom that looks she's
like wait a second
I wasn't able to get
the career advancement
maybe they wanted, because
I had to wait for boomers
to age out, and now my
kids have to wear masks
because a bunch of
septuagenarians are
worried about this,
and I think that we're
experiencing the kind of
the climax of
generational tension.
And we saw this, I'll say
one final thing in this Dave,
which is, this is nothing new.
This kind of immoral behavior
first manifested itself
through fiscal policy.
A generation that was willing
to borrow hundreds of billions
of dollars to add
to the national debt
in 2009, 2010, 2011,
2012, with no regard
for the fiscal health
of future generations is
the same type of generation
that locks down seventh
graders and doesn't think
anything of it.
It's like that we just
do that around here.
Okay, like we'll put
their life on hold,
we'll steal their savings,
we'll steal their purchasing
power 'cause I'm
important, and I matter.
And I think that really,
I think that betrays
the social contract.
I think it goes directly
against what it means
to be a patriotic citizen.
- You say 35 to 54 are gonna
be the red pill generation.
It's like I'm 45, I know
a little something about
this red pill situation, right?
So it's like, I'm with
you man, I feel it.
You see those those pictures
online of Stacy Abrams unmasked
in front of the kids, and
Hochul over in New York
smiling with the kids.
It's like these kids are
gonna do some pretty horrible
things to old people, one
day, you can really feel it.
Do you not not just to talk
about it at an ideal level,
but because you're around
so many college kids,
kids, I mean they're young
adults, through Turning Point,
have you seen a real shift in
their attitudes on this stuff?
We go to the events, when I
go to Turning Point events
it's always so positive and
fun, and all that stuff,
but like have you seen
a difference in the way
they're reacting with
the ideas or resentment
or whatever it might be?
- Definitely on the
center right, for sure.
Our students are
pushing back like crazy.
We have we have a list, I
was just going through it,
we have 35 schools that
have staged walkouts
in the last 24 hours
at Turning Point USA
over the mask mandates,
and we support them 100%.
We're helping them with PR
support and times legal support,
all that stuff because
the mask mandates
have gone out of control,
but I will say Dave,
that the mass propaganda,
dare I say, mass formation
psychosis (indistinct)
- Uh oh, trying to get
us both taken out man?
- Yeah, there we go,
well, I figure this will be on
local, so we know the owner,
they won't-
- Goodbye, Spotify.
- So, yeah exactly,
but that kind of
mass propaganda campaign
has really worked
on a lot of young people,
and it's kind of a
great irony where,
and this is a stereotype,
but the average 70 year old,
60 or 70 year old right
now is far less concerned
about COVID than I think
the average 17 year old.
And that's a stereotype,
that's like a generalization,
I should say, but there has
been a lot of induced fear
amongst high school
and college kids,
completely and
totally unnecessarily,
and there's a cost
to pay for that.
It's gonna be a generation
that is the least
free thinking generation,
absent our intervention,
and trying to get them
their humanity back.
It's the most
medicated generation,
most suicidal generation,
the most confused generation,
the most directionalist
generation, but I we're starting
to see some pushback against
this and some hopefully writing
of that trajectory, but I
don't think it's enough.
I don't think that this
is going to fix itself.
I think that we need and
I don't say this lightly,
you know that I'm a small
government conservative guy,
but I think that we need
a collective intervention
to try to fix some of these
trends that have gone so awry.
I don't just think
that we're like,
"Oh well, we shut everything
down for two years.
We vaccinated who
kids didn't need it,
and put masks on them.
They had no social development.
They are not speaking
the way they should.
The IQs are stunted.
Like everything's gonna
kinda sort itself out."
Not as convinced of that,
I'm not, I think there's some
very interesting bold
robust entrepreneurial
and creative ideas that
could probably fix this,
but I'll be honest, Dave,
there's been a little glimmer
of hope amongst some
of the young people,
but it's nowhere near the
type of rebellion that I would
like to see.
It isn't.
I saw far more
activism and energy
around Greta Thunberg's
"The world is ending"
climate change propaganda
and far more energy
amongst the average high school
kid around Floida Palooza
than I did around mask
mandates, vaccine mandates,
or being locked down
and not being able
to see their friends.
- Yeah and you're not
overstating this stuff.
I just read this crazy study
about what masks have done
to adolescent children who
are now having all sorts
of delayed speech.
Literally the muscles in their
mouths are not developing
the way that they are supposed
to because they don't move
their mouths, and they
don't talk enough,
and they can't see the
mouth of the teacher,
so you can mimic it
to speak properly,
I mean it's really
really crazy stuff.
What do you think of the pivot
that they're about to do?
We can see it happening
right in front of our eyes.
They are the good guys.
They didn't wanna lock us down.
They're gonna somehow pin this
on that was the Republicans
that did it.
They're all just
repeating this stuff
that Charlie Kirk
that Ron DeSantis
was saying two years
ago, but Charlie Kirk
was probably saying
some of it too.
- Yeah we were saying
the same thing.
- Do you admire the pivot
that they're about to do?
That they're in the
process of doing right now?
- Do I admire it?
No. I think it's
good for the country.
Yeah It's better now than 10
years from now, sure, good.
Terrific.
But I mean look I
don't say this lightly,
there needs to be justice.
People need to go to
jail for what they did.
There needs to be some sort
of mass firing campaign
de credentialing campaign.
None of that's probably gonna
happen, I'll be very honest.
- Yeah. But what would
that really look like?
Cause I've kinda
thought about it,
like I do think some of these
people probably in a really
sane society that would
grapple with this properly,
some of these people
would end up in jail.
Like literally in jail.
But I don't know, what
does that really look like?
We're gonna have a
Nuremberg for COVID I mean-
- I would love Nuremberg,
but I mean some people say
that's radical, but I mean
there is I think a lot
of the tenants
of Nuremberg happened-
- Well, there's the media
matters clip for today.
- Well, no, I mean, we've
done entire shows on Nuremberg
but yeah sure, but they could
pick it up, and run with it.
But that's probably
not gonna happen.
I try to live in
the land of reality.
I don't think that's
gonna happen anytime soon.
What I would like to
see though happen,
Dave, is a legitimate public
policy and legislative campaign
around medical autonomy,
around medical freedom
and I think we there's
a lot of answers
we yet we still do not have.
We do not have answers
around the money flow
from a lot of these
pharmaceutical companies
to politicians or
their campaigns.
We do not have answers as
to why early treatments
were suppressed.
We've been a very outspoken
program on ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine,
azithromycin, melatonin,
aspirin, monoclonal antibodies,
intravenous therapy,
vitamin D levels.
I think it's one of the
great injustices of my life,
the fact that most Americans
were not properly exposed
to those things,
but don't worry,
we're subsidizing crack
cocaine pipes for people
in San Francisco all the
while, the controlled substance
our government cares about
is the perfectly safe
and probably very very
effective ivermectin it's-
- Dude, Biden sent me three
crack pipes, I only need one.
You want me to send you one?
- Is that, I wouldn't
know what to do with it,
to be very honest, so,
haven't exactly ventured
into that domain
of human existence.
So yeah-
- You're a good man,
Charlie Kirk.
- Yeah, he'd give me
lip balm in case my lips
get too chapped while
smoking crack on the
in Fisherman's Wharf in San
Francisco, but yeah, look,
what would justice look like?
I don't know, but we definitely
need some action, right?
We need legislative changes.
We also, I think
just from a more
constitutional perspective,
we have to make sure
the emergency use powers
are never used again
by these governors and mayors,
I know that might
be wishful thinking,
but I think in some red states
they were used and abused
way too much, I think these
legislatures have to step up
and look, if you wanna
shut down a state,
go to the legislative process.
I totally, I would say
that's fine, if like,
you can get the Ohio State
House and State Senate
to shut down a
state for 30 days,
I actually think that's okay.
I think that the courts might
knock it down here and there,
but just like the fact that a
governor can just sign a piece
of paper and shut
down bars and schools,
that's I think that's
a usurpation of what
the Constitution,
especially on a
state based level
and definitely a federal level
is supposed to be able to do.
I'll give you another example.
The fact that Joe Biden can
just sign a piece of paper
and say, "You have to wear
a mask on an airplane",
go through the
legislative process.
So those are some remedies
for sure that we have to do
that I think could slow
down kind of this indulgence
of kind of autocratic and
tyrannical behavior we've seen,
but we're not gonna
get the justice
that I would wanna see, Dave.
I think that any doctor that
interfered with a patient
trying to get ivermectin or
hydroxychloroquine needs to be
held criminally accountable.
And I don't say that lightly.
And Dave, you get a lot of
e-mails, I get a ton of e-mails.
I have hundreds of
e-mails of people
that have relatives that
died in the hospital
and they were trying to give
them these life saving drugs
and the hospital says, "Oh
those drugs might kill them,"
and then they die.
And so it's like what
we're dealing from already
the potential of we know
death is in the cards,
so why wouldn't you try it?
Some of the more, let's
say, censored treatments
and so I think there needs
to be justice with that,
and the hospitals need
be held accountable,
but just kinda
managing expectations,
that's probably
not gonna happen.
But the last thing you
said do I admire it?
No, I don't admire it.
Why are they doing it?
Well, the science
has not changed,
no matter what Dr. Wen says.
- Leana Wen said it changed,
- The political science
- come on.
- has changed.
- Yeah I mean look
and this is the thing,
is that trust the science,
trust the science.
We did a whole podcast on this
that I think it was really
well received.
One of the best podcasts
we've done in a while,
as far as like response,
which is that they conflate
two things right?
So they conflate things that
we would call the natural law,
like force equals mass
times acceleration,
the irrefutable tenants
of Western science right?
The increon to
the natural world.
Second law of thermodynamics,
the inevitable law of decay,
and they conflate
that with conjecture
and hypothesis, right?
So they put that all
into kinda the same term
as if you challenge
wearing three masks
while you shower, you're
somehow at war with Copernicus.
And like the average
engineer who works at Ford,
is like, "Well I'm
trained in the sciences,
I don't ever wanna question
that," when in reality,
they had that which we
know, and that which
we think we know, and they
were never honest enough
to separate those two things.
- Charlie you're blowing
my mind right now.
I gotta write this down.
Are you telling me that A
squared plus B squared equals C
squared is more valid than
when you're at a restaurant
you can walk in without
a mask and when you,
or when you have a mask and
you walk in and you can take it
off when you sit are is that
what you're telling me here?
- I'm telling that,
I know it might really
blow your audience's mind
that the things we know in the
Western scientific tradition
that have been true that
really proven to be the
laws of nature, in nature's
God which Thomas Jefferson
brilliantly wrote in the
Declaration is far better
science than vaccinating
a six month old
with a vaccine against
a virus that isn't
gonna harm them
significantly anyway,
or let's just think of all this,
the scientific calesthetics
that we've heard
in just the last couple weeks.
Was it Eric Garcetti
said he held his breath
when he took a picture
at SoFi stadium
or Gavin Newsom, he said,
"Well I just took a picture,
I put the mask back on,"
Or Dr. Vivek Murthy who said
you have to wear masks at
home around your children.
That was in the
last couple months.
And we know the science
is totally insane.
I mean you take the mask
mandate on planes, for example.
that's right, it's the
only virus in the history
of communicable diseases
that does not come out
as soon as the beverage
cart comes out.
It stops.
It's so scared of
- It's incredible.
- Of the hot, hot coffee
and the sanitized Coke cans
that it stops all transmission.
But from going from New York
to LA for a year and a half
of the pandemic you
could not go eat indoors,
but if you to go eat indoors
just go board American Airlines
at JFK and fly to LAX.
- But we all folded.
We all kind of folded.
I said to my guys it's
like, "I'm doing just fine,
I'm not complaining about life,
but my goal after these
last two years is to become
so rich I never have to
fly commercial again."
'Cause I flew private twice
for the first time ever
in this past year and they've
made the flying experience,
even though yes, you
can take off your mask
to drink your coffee, and
eat your small chicken.
It just ain't right
what they're doing.
But do you think the
federal mask mandate,
I mean I haven't
heard any talk about
they're gonna stop
it on airplanes,
and we've got idiots like
Swalwell pushing it forever.
- Do I-
- He also slept
with a Chinese spy but
that's a whole other thing.
- That I mean, yeah.
I don't know if he did
it on a plane or not,
that would be a very
interesting chapter two
of the Fang Fang diaries.
- Long as he add his mask on.
- Yeah, that's right,
I mean that's correct.
So, do I think the federal
mask mandate will be lifted?
No, and you actually you make
a really important point,
which is because the people in
charge aren't affected by it.
Like Biden doesn't
fly commercial.
Flies Air Force One.
- Yep.
- I mean and so-
- But he always puts
his mask on right
before he gets off Air Force
One, I always love that
when it's like oh yeah yeah
you guys been wearing it
on the helicopter on
Air Force One, okay.
- And it's COVID theater, but
this goes to a deeper point
that the founding fathers
warned us against,
and the more we kind of dwell
and we marinate and ruminate
on the brilliance and the
wisdom of the founding fathers,
we realized they saw
a lot of this coming,
which I think in Federalist
51, or one of those associate,
Madison warned what would
happen if the group of rulers
are exempt from the laws that
they push upon the citizenry?
And that's why Congress
technically can't pass laws
that they are immune from.
They found carve outs
and ways to do that,
but the federal mask
mandate on airplanes
is a perfect example of this,
which is a vast majority
of the members of Congress,
and especially people financing
the members of Congress,
they're totally
unaffected by it.
And their kids go to
private schools where
there are no mask mandates
and they fly on private jets
where there's no mask mandates.
And yeah, look governor
Newsalini married into
the Sebel family.
I don't know the last
time he flew commercial.
He's flying around probably
on a Gulf stream or a Learjet
or whatever, and I guarantee
you the family's not masking
when they hit 15,000
or 20,000 feet.
No, they're having a great time
and they're laughing about it.
- Charlie they spent 200
grand on a one week vacation
in Cabo about three
months ago, right?
The same week he extended
his emergency powers.
I don't live there
anymore by the way,
very exciting.
Can't you tell look at me?
- Yeah, you're happier,
you're paying more taxes.
You've become more conservative,
which is just delightful,
but yeah It's and we
call it hypocrisy.
It's not.
It's hierarchy, Dave.
It's not hypocrisy.
- Yeah.
- It's I am better than you.
I'm gonna crush you
and I don't care.
- Yeah, he's a bad dude.
But all right, I know we
can go on this stuff forever
but let's link some of
this to the big tech stuff
that you and I have been
talking about forever.
And as you said,
we're both involved
in the Rumble situation.
You were sorta early on
with the Rumble team.
Obviously, locals
merged with Rumble,
there's a lot going on there.
Do you honestly think
we have a chance?
I mean, to even just in
the last couple days,
look we put our
best foot forward.
We made this offer to Joe Rogan.
He may not take it, but we
felt it was the best thing
we could do to defend
our principles and fight
for what we believe in.
We shall see.
We're fighting on every front.
The payment processor
front, the AWS front,
the algorithm front, but do
you think we can really do it?
- We don't have a choice.
We have to win.
We have to get this right
or else everything
we love falls apart.
I have been so
encouraged, though,
just in the last 12 months,
Dave, how much momentum
there is behind this kind
of new technology space.
From locals which is terrific,
which is a way to bypass
the Patreon gatekeepers,
to the content creators
that have gone all in on Rumble.
You, our program, Dan
Bongino, Dinesh D'Souza,
Russell Brand, Tulsi
Gabbard, freedom loving,
liberty loving people
all across the spectrum,
but do believe that
Big Tech tyranny
is an existential threat.
I thought the offer to
Rogan was really brilliant.
I don't know Rogan,
I've met him once.
I think it would be really
smart of him personally
to take the Rumble deal because
they are not going to stop.
This this censorship
hit job train.
He says, "Oh Spotify
stood by me."
I don't think so.
They're removing episodes
and putting disclaimers.
You and I are way too
cynical for that, Dave.
We've been through this
entire program many times
and maybe a couple years
ago we might have said that,
but look it's, the Rumble
was really smart to offer
the 100 million dollars
'cause it made it legit,
and I don't, we'll see if what
we'll see what Rogan ends up
doing, right?
I mean he's signaled
towards Spotify or whatever,
but the point is that it wasn't
totally laughed off, Dave,
and that shows how
real Rumble is.
That shows that we can win this.
So to answer your question
on a probability argument,
I first made a moral argument.
We have to win this.
We have to do this.
I think Rumble's gonna be a 20
or 30 or $40 billion company.
I'm confident of that because
there is a center right
of the planet, not
just the country,
that is desiring a platform
that actually allows voices
to speak their mind
and not be taken off
and not have these sort of
woke gatekeepers, but look,
there are going to be
institutional challenges
but I know we keep
talking about Rumble,
but they're not alone,
there's other people in play,
but Rumble's definitely the
most sophisticated I think,
best funded, and most momentum.
I think that I think that
it's ahead of schedule
and I think that
there's gonna be starts
I think some chatter already
in Silicon Valley of what
are we gonna do about
these Rumble guys?
Well, you can't shut
off their servers.
You could probably go after
their advertisers for now,
but then you got locals which
is hundreds of thousands
of grassroots people
supporting people via Patreon
which is gonna be incredibly
effective to be able
to kinda have the super
chat feature of videos,
which is a huge revenue
source for Google.
There'll be institutional ads
that will always go behind
Rumble that are on
the center right.
And so what else do they
kinda have in the tickler file
to try to go after Rumble?
Okay, they're gonna try to
go after the ad network,
they're gonna try to go
after New York Times,
Washington Post, your
platforming hateful people.
Yeah, but when you start to
have a roster of Dave Rubin,
Charlie Kirk, Daily
Wire is coming online
is what I'm hearing, you
have Dan Bongino and others,
all of a sudden you're
like, "Yeah, okay,
we're gonna link arms and
we've created tech NATO,
and we have article six
and you attack one of us-"
- Tech NATO.
You didn't just come
up with that did you?
You've used that one before,
come on.
- I've never said it
out loud but I have
wrote it, I have a whole,
I have a whole pamphlet
of kinda one liners,
but you could use
it, Tech NATO and-
- Tech NATO.
- It's article five
or article six of NATO,
which is attack on one of us
is attack on all of us.
And to kinda tie in the
whole Ukrainian thing,
that's why Ukraine in NATO is
such a controversial thing.
It's like Putin crosses
the line, it's the same
as invading Paris or London.
And it's like, okay you
go after Dave Rubin,
then you have to
deal with all of us,
and our combined power,
and our combined followers,
and I'm starting to see that
solidarity, and guess what?
That word solidarity
is something
that we freedom loving
people don't do well.
But when we do it, we win.
It's not in our blood.
We're all entrepreneurs
or individuals.
We think we could do things
better than each other.
We're competitors.
We'll go out to dinner with one
another and they'll be like,
"Yeah I kinda like that idea
and that," like whatever,
but that's what's
beautiful about markets,
but now we're at war
and we need solidarity
and we need alliances so I
think we got a chance to win.
- I like that every
time I'm on your show
when I say something clever
you always say to me,
"I'm stealing that,"
but I'm gonna credit
you for this Tech NATO.
- You got it.
- That's the difference.
That's the difference
between us,
Charlie.
- That's right,
the attribution.
- But do you see okay, so
let's say we build this stuff
and it's all great and I
and you, yes, we are working
real hard and there's
a lot of questions,
but there's a lot
of answers as well,
so we start building all that.
We know that the trends
where people are moving
are going very heavily
to freedom loving places.
Nobody's moving to
blue states right now.
I think California lost almost
400,000 people last year.
First loss of population ever.
As these things
continue to go, I mean
what keeps us the United States?
If we've just got
our own products,
and we've got our own states
and they've got their products
and their states,
where are we united?
- Well, we aren't,
and you're right.
And so just to kinda
reinforce the point though,
Netflix is down, Facebook
is down, California is down,
Florida is up, Texas
up, Rumble is up.
So look I've said this
for quite some time.
I think we're living
through a slow motion
secession movement and
the act of secession
is happening on United
Airlines every day
in the nonstop flight from
Los Angeles to Orlando
or from Los Angeles to Miami.
It's a movement of
secession and it's not,
it's not a one that breaks
the country apart immediately,
but they're starting to say
out loud what I have feared,
and it's mostly pop icon
people, Sarah Silverman
or that guy from Hell
Boy whatever his name is.
- Oh that nut bag Ron Perlman.
- Yeah whatever,
and they're saying it out loud,
"I don't wanna live in
the country with you,
you don't wanna live with me,
let's go our separate ways."
And a very provocative but
honest thought exercise
for your audience and for all
of us to kind of dwell over
which is, what do I, Charlie
Kirk, who live in Phoenix,
what do I have in common with
a San Francisco woke activist
that's 24 years old that just
graduated from UC Berkeley?
I believe America's awesome.
They believe America's awful.
I believe in basic
natural rights.
They believe in collective
and tribal rights.
I believe in free speech.
They believe in power.
I believe that we
should have borders.
They don't believe in borders.
I could go through
the whole checklist.
The only thing that
we have in common
is the dollar bill
that we're trading.
It's literally the whole
project is basically hinging
on my currency and that is
not an over exaggeration.
You don't have a shared story.
You don't have shared values.
You don't have a shared future.
You don't have a shared
policy prescriptions.
Everything is quote unquote
politicized and divided,
and so we've kinda dwelled in
this field to the great cost
of being written up
in media matters,
which is a wonderful
thing to happen,
they're like PR experts.
- They love you over there.
They like you more than me,
with all the pieces
they do on you.
- It's great.
They write up what you
say and it's right there
and then you could share
it like, "Hey look it,"
but we are we are
right on the hinge.
We're right on the edge
of a national divorce.
Now, I have a contrarian
view on this which is
I actually think the sooner
we build the parallel economy
and we have these other mediums,
I actually think it
de-escalates the chance
for a national divorce.
I think it's the exact opposite.
- Yeah I like that.
- Actually, it's kind of
like, "All right you do you,
we do us, like maybe we
can have like a five year
cooling off period
before we actually
sign the divorce papers."
And I don't think, I think
the more that we live
under their tyranny, you're
gonna see real radicalism
rise up that I
hate, and you hate.
Where people are starting to
talk about things that I don't
want the country to break up.
I think it's an awful thing.
It's my home.
It's your home.
I don't wanna have to show
a passport when I go to LAX.
It's like I want that to
be my fellow countryman.
I don't know if
they believe that.
I think that they wanna-
There's two, there's two
thoughts on this, right,
which is most of the
leftist rulers will reject
a national divorce 'cause
they want the whole enchilada.
They want every county,
they want every inch,
and they want us to
live in their tyranny.
Like they are up at night,
really angry that some
Baptist preacher in Enid,
Oklahoma is not like perfectly
in alignment with every single
one of their worldviews.
Like that really bothers them.
Where it's like, as a
conserve, I don't really care
about some guy in
Brooklyn that hates me.
Like okay, whatever.
It's so who's the actual
liberal in this equation?
Like who's the live
and let live guy.
It's like is it the
Baptist preacher
or the conservative in Phoenix?
Or is it like the person in
Brooklyn that's really angry
that someone disagrees
with them in central Iowa.
But that's part of
it, but I think that,
so those are the kinda
the Imperial Democrats.
They wanna take over territory.
It's like, we are not going
to stop till everyone succumbs
to our agenda.
And then the other side
of it though, are like
the Sarah Silverman,
Ron Perlman types
which they're actually being
more humble and honest,
I have to say, that I have
way more respect for people
that are like let's just
break up and not fight.
And that's actually a
better starting point
than like, "We're gonna
take over Kansas."
Like well hold hold
all on a second,
probably not gonna ha-
that's not in the cards.
Does that does that make sense?
- Yeah, but can I put
a fly in that ointment
on the second one for you,
which is they're saying,
"Let's break up and
just that's it,"
but they'll never let that be.
I think you you would
agree with that, right?
If we if we give them the
breakup that they want,
Sarah Silverman
gets what she wants.
It's like she'll never stop.
She's not gonna stop
as Florida flourishes,
as Arizona flourishes,
and Texas flourishes,
and as their places
just crumble.
They're not gonna stop.
Now they're gonna
want what we got,
so the second one
might be more honest,
but it's not, I don't think
it's fully thought through
let's say.
- No it's not
thought through and
look there's and I,
this is not an over exaggerate-
there's a thousand
externalities that I don't
have answers for:
military, water rights,
ports of entry.
Who gets rights to minerals?
How do you travel
back and forth?
How do you divide
the citizenship?
What if you don't
wanna live there?
I mean it's like, again
we have if we actually
put our heads together,
there's enough mature people
that could probably
figure this out,
but if we're dealing
with Chuck Schumer,
I don't know, that's
probably not gonna go well,
do you know what I mean?
He's like no, no, no,
no actually I want
Marshalton, Iowa.
Like you can't have it, right?
(Dave laughs)
- And so yeah, that's why
I, and you, we want to heal
this land.
We want this to work.
We want this Republic
to stay together.
I don't think there is a
manageable exit from this.
And I don't, I would rather
solve this with ballots
than bullets as
Abraham Lincoln said.
And I don't want this
to go to conflict.
I'm afraid it's
trending that way,
and the media always says
like, "Oh, Charlie thinks
the Civil War's coming."
First of all, I
never used that term,
but when I say conflict,
I don't think that's out
of the cards.
I don't want that to happen,
but you can only raise
the temperature in
the room so much
before you kinda provoke
a kinetic response.
And so I actually think the
parallel economy is going to be
an unintended
pressure release valve
for liberty-loving people
across the country,
which is like okay, now
I at least have a place
I can watch videos.
Now I have a place I can bank.
Now I have a place I
can get a mortgage.
And I think that's
gonna hopefully bring
the temperature down in the
room, despite the best wishes
the other side that seems
like they want conflict,
which is a whole
different conversation
for a different time.
It seems like they
want us to punch first
and then they could justify
the security state apparatus
behind it.
- Yeah, this concept of
building the parallel economy
purely to keep it together,
is actually interesting
'cause most people think of
it as, "Oh that accelerates
the separation,
'cause then we can
just go our separate
ways," but I like this
I like this release valve
idea Kirk, you got one today.
- Thank you.
- Very impressed.
- Thank you, thank you.
- You got one.
All right, now, let me get
you in some real trouble.
- Okay here we go.
- 'Cause everybody
is looking to the midterms,
and there's this feeling
that there's gonna
be this red wave,
although as I said we're
seeing the pivot happen
in real time, and you
can also feel the media
trying to link January 6th
to somehow the truckers
and that we're exporting
a worldwide insurrection,
and all of this nonsense,
but I wanna ask you this:
Well A, I guess gimme a
little bit of your take
on what you think is gonna
happen in the midterms
and are there areas we
could focus in to make sure
that we get a nice result,
but B, everyone's looking
at the 2024 situation.
I want DeSantis to stay
the governor of Florida.
That's what I want.
I think the state you live
in is way more important.
I think he's only been
in one term so far
he's done a heck of a job,
I just think that's more
important than the
presidency, believe it or not.
Although obviously
it is important.
Do you as a guy that at least
part-time lives in Florida
or is there a lot, do
you like that idea?
Do you think he should run?
Where does Trump fall out?
What do you know on the inside?
The whole damn
thing Charlie. Go.
- I'll start with the midterms.
I think Republicans
are gonna do well.
I'm worried that we're not
gonna do nearly as we should.
Every single indicator
shows Republicans
are gonna take back the House.
Senate is a little
bit up for grabs.
This should be a 60 or
70 year seat majority
for the House representatives,
which is enough
where you could hold
onto that for at least
two or three more cycles.
So I don't know.
It remains to be seen.
Democrats are gonna try to
correct a couple things.
You could start to
see that already.
They're having Obama come
in and try to tell them
to not be so radical out loud.
He's really good at
kind of saying like-
- Right, he does it on the DL.
- Stop telling the truth.
Like that's kind of his whole
deal, to try to tell people
that are running
for office to just
camouflage the radicalism.
Just tell people
what they wanna hear.
So I think that they're
gonna, I think they're gonna
get their parade
in order, shortly.
That's my warning
to Republicans.
I still think we're
gonna do very very well.
Especially in some
of these Senate races
like Arizona and Georgia.
I think it'll be a seven
to 10 point swing on top
of what things naturally are.
I'm afraid, I'll reinforce
a point I said earlier,
I think it will be a misleading
indicator of the health
of the Republican party
because of how bad
the Democrats are.
This will be a massive
indictment of the woke
and the Democrats and the
insane, and the COVID lockdowns,
where people are just looking
for some way that they can
just like what can I
vote for that isn't them?
I think Virginia
was an example that.
I think the incredibly
unexpected airtight race
in New Jersey was
an example of that.
I think a Republican winning
the city attorney's race
in Seattle was an
example of that.
That's all back in November,
but it's important to
remind people of that.
- [Dave] Yep, yep.
- So that's one thing I'm
happy to go more into that.
It's still, it's too early
to kinda make predictions
on like seat majorities,
but I am not seeing
from Republicans
what I really want,
which is a Newt Gingrich
style contract with America,
promises clear and concise,
here's what we're going to do,
and it's not just free
trade and giving China
what they want and and mass
amnesty plan and lower taxes
and socialism is bad.
Enough, right ?
I think voters want
more than that,
and I think they want honesty.
So on the Trump thing in 2024,
he is going to run,
every single indication
points towards that.
I think actually
Trump will benefit
from a primary challenge.
I think that if he actually
has to run against somebody
who isn't a joke, I actually
think that would really
be good for him.
I think that's one of
the things that made him
such a powerful general
election candidate in 2016
because he had some
of the most amazing
metaphorical political CrossFit
training one could have.
I mean he ran up against
like 29,000 people.
It was like 16 but it was
like from every direction.
It was like boom Scott
Walker, and boom Ben Carson,
it was like Jeb
Bush and Ted Cruz.
He was like nonstop.
By the time he had a run
against Hillary he was like,
I ran against 16
people, this is nothing.
So I think that, I'm not
trying to encourage someone
to run against him, I would
rather see him obviously
go unopposed if
that's necessary,
it's probably better
for him in the sense
of not having to
spend as much money,
but I actually think kind
of shaking off kind of some
of the dust and getting back
into the metaphorical ring
could be really
really good for him.
As far as DeSantis goes,
I think he's unbelievable.
I think he's the greatest
governor of the last 10 or 20
or 30 years.
I can't think of
a better governor.
Ron DeSantis has done
everything right,
in everything issue
that matters to me
from vaccine mandates,
to opening up Florida,
to being strong on
crime across the board.
He's been phenomenal.
I think someone like
DeSantis or it could be him
is the future of the
Republican party, I truly do.
But Trump's gonna run and
that's gonna be a challenge
for a lot of people.
I think that once you win
one presidential election
you deserve a chance to
run again, I really do.
In 2020 there were a
massive irregularities,
happy to get into all the
kinda voter fraud conversation,
if you want, I think
Dinesh D'Souza's new film
is extraordinary in
what it looks into
and the evidence is
very very compelling,
I think if some of that
could be shored up.
I think Trump could
win again, and look,
I think that there's
positives and negatives
to him running again.
The positives are he was
a terrific president.
He was tremendous.
We know what we're getting.
He has a base unlike
anything we've ever seen,
he'll raise a bunch of of money
in small dollar donations,
he'll work his tail off,
and I think that he also
has a record to run on in
contrast to this current
absolute dumpster fire that
we are seeing in real time.
And also make no mistake,
I don't think people
are really looking
forward to having
another Democrat president
after four years.
If we had, I want people
to think about this,
if we had a parliamentary
system, and there was right now
a national vote of no
confidence against Joe Biden,
he'd get run out of
there immediately.
Now, we don't have
that type of system.
We just don't, but if the
election were held today,
Donald Trump would just
clobber him in every,
like he would win
like 40 states.
I think he would
win New Hampshire.
He'd win Nevada, and so
look I also think though
that Trump has to have, he
has to make some adjustments
going in 2024.
If you're running up against
a self-destructive candidate,
do not get in the way of
your enemy defeating himself.
I think that was something
that's a great learning lesson
from 2020, and I
think 2016 Trump
where he was big,
bold, and ambitious,
and he was willing to
capture the imagination
of the American people, I
think has to play a little bit
more into that.
It's hard when you're an
incumbent to do that, I get it,
but 2016 Trump he
made people dream.
He really pushed the
boundaries of what a political
candidate is allowed
to talk about.
I think he could
recapture that in a very
very compelling way in 2024.
- Charlie Kirk future
political consultant.
- Yeah, right.
- It's been a pleasure
talking to you, my friend.
I will see you probably,
I sense it will be
on the west coast of Florida.
What do you think?
- West coast of Florida
is the place to be.
I, my place in Florida
will not be disclosed
but it's not too far from
Rumble's headquarters.
The heartbeat of the response
to the Silicon Valley tyranny,
so, honored Dave thank you.
And check out my
locals everybody.
It's gonna be great.
- It's
charliekirk.locals.com right?
- That's right, that's correct.
- See ya brother.
- See you soon.
Thank you
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our
politics playlists,
and if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics watch our
full episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.